[Aplausos]
[Música]
boa noite
toda vez que é se introduz uma nova
tecnologia de comunicação uma nova mídia
na nossa sociedade a gente experimenta
uma revolução
quem disse isso foi março na globo
o filósofo canadense estudioso da área
da comunicação dos seus impactos
especialmente os culturais sobre a
civilização
ele acreditava que quando você
introduzir uma nova mídia criava-se toda
uma nova atmosfera dentro da qual ea se
desenvolver uma nova cultura amplamente
influenciada por essa nova metodologia
ele acreditava que as mídias tinham
impacto sensorial sobre o ser humano que
ele mudava a nossa própria maneira de
pensar a sua frase célebre é o meio é a
mensagem
embora pareça simples muitas vezes é mal
interpretada
ele acreditava que quando você ler um
livro por exemplo que é uma mídia pra
ele 'você tá ficando individualista
independente do conteúdo pode ser
comédia pode ser drama tanto faz
você está ficando individualista porque
pela mecânica pela qual você consome o
livro é um rito individual você não
consegue ler um livro e conversar com
outras pessoas ao mesmo tempo na verdade
você ler de forma serial palavra por
palavra linha por linha página por
página isso vai se tornando mais
mecânico mais metódico mais serial ao
contrário da tv a tv na verdade é algo
que torna mais colete vista mais como
nal quando você vai assistir tv é normal
até você convidar outras pessoas para
assistir ao mesmo tempo com você não é
então essa é uma experiência que vai se
tornando mais coletivo que transforma
dessa maneira que a internet também é
uma nova mídia então transformar
durou mais quanto estas mesmo porque ela
tem multimídias nem dentro dela tem
livro você tem vídeo você tem uma série
de coisas
lá atrás o gutenberg quando ele
introduziu a prensa no mundo que
popularizou é o conteúdo extra para as
classes mais baixas
simplesmente as classes mais baixas não
sabiam ler e nem se dignava aprender a
ler porque não vale a pena quanto
custava um livro nessa época se custasse
7 mil reais
você compraria um livro era mais ou
menos o que custava nessa época eles
eram feitos à mão hoje custa 50 60 reais
a gente não compra nem muitas vezes
imagina como foi transformadora a
introdução da prensa de gutenberg que
criou uma sociedade que ele chamou de
mecânica na era mecânica quando se
introduziu as mídias elétricas e aí eu
estou colocando o telégrafo
o rádio a tv a gente também teve uma
transformação enorme
imagina quanto tempo demorava para uma
notícia chegar tipo rei da inglaterra
morreu na américa como ela viajava
garante não haver demorava dois meses
para isso impacta lá então não acontecia
meio devagar meio serial
depois que inventaram o telégrafo quando
o rei morreu imediatamente américa
ficava sabendo então imagina o impacto
disso o mundo começa a acontecer em
paralelo e acelera também né
outro efeito dessas mídias foi que o
mundo encolheu
porque se você pode conversar com uma
pessoa do outro lado do globo
instantaneamente quer dizer que é como
se eu estivesse aqui fisicamente
presente né
a voz dela pelo menos estava está
conversando com ela então esses efeitos
o mec lohan chamou e de o termo de
aldeia global que o mundo tenha dado uma
encolhida e ele tende a caminhar para
esse daí pra virar uma grande aldeia
global
com a gente é conviver como nos tempos
antigos
é a internet quando chegou ela
trocou um pouquinho um paradigma
importante na comunicação os livros o
rádio ea tv
eles são unidirecionais o nosso consumo
dessas tecnologias é mais passivo quando
você está assistindo tv você não
conversa com william bonner né
quando você lê um livro você não dialoga
com o autor então é um em um consumo
passivo unidirecional já com a internet
não isso mudou com a internet você está
assistindo alguma live no youtube está
interagindo imediatamente
instantaneamente com quem está
produzindo
quando você lê o blog você pode comentar
interagir com o autor
isso é bastante transformador a internet
trouxe uma série de transformações na
nossa a sociedade na nossa civilização a
gente está vendo aí transformações na
hora política econômica mercadológica
mas uma das transformações que não é tão
evidente é como ela está mudando o nosso
conceito de fronteiras
quando eu tô falando fronteiras estou
dizendo não ter as físicas mesmo que
separam as cidades estados países
continentes
essas essas fronteiras
elas começam a não fazer mais tanto
sentido especialmente para a nova
geração os chamados nativos digitais
pensa por exemplo no teletrabalho como
funcionava o teletrabalho 30 anos atrás
se é que funcionava há 30 anos atrás se
você quiser se arrumar um emprego nos
estados unidos você teria que fazer o
que tirar o seu visto viajar aos estados
unidos e arrumar um emprego por lá você
tivesse essa necessidade de movimentação
física
hoje em dia a gente tem sites que são
especializados em arrumar emprego pra
gente no mundo inteiro remoto
isso é bem bacana então hoje você pode
trabalhar para americana você pode
trabalhar por um australiano mas também
outras consequências eu sou empresário
de software e tem empresa portuguesa e
americana contratando aqui em maringá
porque maringá um pólo de software não
sei se vocês sabem tem muita gente
competente aqui não tem esse outro
efeito aí
fronteira física já não impede mais que
isso aconteça
antigamente a gente tinha os efeitos da
globalização e os mercados que a gente
disputava mundialmente sim mas agora até
a mão de obra não ver mais esse limite
da fronteira física
isso é bastante transformador também eu
gosto também de observar o youtube souto
vez produzem conteúdo dos mais variados
sobre qualquer tema de qualquer lugar do
mundo e são consumidos por qualquer
pessoa de qualquer lugar do mundo é bem
democrático nesse sentido não precisa
morar nos estados unidos para assistir
um programa do youtube americano
o raio não sei se vocês já viram rafael
menininho que faz programas no youtube
no qual ele abre brinquedos e fala da
experiência dele em 2018 ranking ganhou
22 milhões de dólares fazendo isso
isso é uma indústria né
é uma maneira de viver já a minha
sobrinha ela conhece o raia ela não sabe
escrever
ela é uma nativa digital já como ela
encontra um raio
ela assiste à tv ver o brinquedo gravar
o nome vai no youtube a perto aquele
microfone zin diz o nome do brinquedo e
magicamente rainha aparece pra ela pra
ela tanto faz de onde raia é na verdade
pouca gente sabe da onde ele é porque a
mãe dele não revela essa informação
prudentemente é por motivos de segurança
e evidentemente mas ele é americano mas
para minha sobrinha tanto faz e onde ele
é na verdade pra ela ele mora no youtube
ela tanto faz então a fronteira física
não impede que esse tipo de coisa
aconteça
vocês percebem como isso é incontrolável
ninguém foi lá ensinar minha família
sobrinha a encontrar ela fez
naturalmente porque ela nasceu dentro
desse novo mais de 7 como uma clã falava
essa essa tecnologia vai moldando a
forma dela pensar pensa nas redes
sociais que mudaram o conceito de
amizade também hoje você pode ter um
amigo de qualquer lugar do mundo por
alguma rede social dessas
fronteira física não impede que você
cria amizades há 30 anos atrás era assim
que acontecia
hoje você casa pela internet né têm
redes sociais específicas para isso
inclusive com estrangeiros então não
raro hoje como era antigamente você de
estrangeiros se casando que se
conheceram pela internet
um outro exemplo que eu acho fantástica
dessas comunidades de jogos online
outro dia estava na casa de um amigo meu
e o filho dele estava com headset na
cabeça nem microfone zinho falando
inglês e falando em inglês
ele tem uns 10 para 11 anos fiquei
espantado e perguntei o que está
acontecendo ali ou não ele está jogando
falei mas ele está falando ele está
conversando com outros caras que estão
jogando com ele falei olha que legal é
esse cara é um da suécia e outro dos
estados unidos
eles jogam frequentemente junto já tem
até uma certa amizade entre eles para
jogar e continuar conversando eu falei
que formidável isso imagina 30 anos
atrás isso era possível antes de ir pro
colégio com um brinco com meu amigo dos
estados unidos da suécia e depois vida
que segue
não né isso também é bastante
transformador
imagina a gente como está mexendo com a
personalidade dessa molecada como eles
estão construindo a própria identidade
deles pra falar de identidade a gente
vai ter que recorrer a um pouco aos
psicólogos e cientistas sociais que
estudaram esse assunto a fundo pra eles
a nossa identidade é formada por três
grandes partes vamos dizer assim o
primeiro é nosso é o pessoal que é ação
são coisas muito particulares como seu
nome sua identidade de gênero sua visão
política coisas mais pessoais íntimas
mesmo
a segunda é o coletivo ou coletivos são
rótulos que a própria sociedade nos
atribui rótulos do tipo marido é médico
advogado cidadão que vão criar uma certa
expectativa de comportamento a seu
respeito e compõe sua identidade
a terceira é o eu relacional e o
relacional é baseado
nas relações cotidianas mais próximas
especialmente que você tem então seria
por exemplo marido e mulher pai filho
professor aluno esse tipo de
relacionamento junto com os outros dois
vão formar então que é a tua
personalidade como você se entende por
gente e isso varia ao longo do tempo é
quando você vai envelhecendo à medida
que esses fatores vão variando também
agora pensa comigo em um século 18 como
isso acontecia
basicamente até os 30 anos você ea
conhecer quase tudo que tinha para se
conhecer né as coisas não variavam com a
velocidade que varia hoje e
provavelmente você conhecer todas as
pessoas que você ia conhecer sua vida
inteira porque não existe avião não
existia carro então as pessoas não
viajavam até aos 30 anos ali pelo menos
90% das pessoas você já teria conhecido
em qualquer efeito disso então sobre a
personalidade muito pouco depois dos 30
anos você ficava ali meio estável né
e hoje como é que funciona lembra do
exemplo dos meninos jogando videogame
ali com um carro a dos estados unidos da
suécia cotidianamente está afetando e
hoje a gente produz mais informação em
duas semanas do que a humanidade levou
seis mil anos para produzir isso também
está afetando a visão de mundo deles
como eles percebem as coisas eu não sei
se vocês sabem mas a história criou o
conceito de cidadão digital a estônia o
país digital
o que isso quer dizer que qualquer
pessoa pode se candidatar se a um
cidadão digital estoniano basta você
preencher um cadastro e submetê las
porque eu ia querer fazer isso porque se
eu for um cidadão digital estoniano eu
posso ter alguns benefícios por exemplo
abrir uma empresa digital na estônia e
usufrui dos benefícios da descida é uma
empresa digital stone ana como por
exemplo acessar o mercado europeu é
interessante não é agora pensa essa
molecada com esse tipo de raciocínio
a mentalidade que se mantém de 7 mais
digital talhado por essa nova mídia que
entrou quando eles crescerem como é que
eles vão fazer quando foi abrir uma
empresa será que eles vão pensar vou
abrir uma empresa aqui no brasil
enfrentar toda essa burocracia que nós
que somos imigrantes digitais aí achamos
que a única maneira de se fazer as
coisas é que ele já tem uma de 7 híbrido
não é puro digital
será que é assim que eles vão querer
fazer as coisas vai ser muito mais
natural pra eles simplesmente chamar
aquele amigo de infância que se formou
em engenharia nos estados unidos
aquele sueco que está craque em
marketing e abrir uma empresa na
história sem que eles tenham que
abandonar fisicamente seus locais ou
talvez vire o nome de digital e fiquei
viajando porque ele também não precisa
está em canto algum fisicamente fixo
para poder ter esse tipo de armas
será que isso não vai ser mais natural
ting perng nesses dias atrás falou uma
frase que achei muito bacana
ele disse assim que no futuro os países
vão disputar os cidadãos assim como hoje
a gente tem as empresas no mercado
global disputando clientes
os países vão disputar os cidadãos já
pensaram nisso eu acho que isso deveria
dar calafrios nossas políticas né
é é um mundo bastante admirável e está à
nossa porta
ele está acontecendo eu gostaria de
estar vivo para ver isso tudo se
consolidar
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]